Welcome everyone to the DDPS seminar.
Before we introduce our invited speaker,
let's go over some rules and logistics.
First, please mute yourself during the
talk.
But if you have questions, you can
unmute and ask questions or use chat
room to post your question so that
we can address them in Q&A session at
the end or during the talk. Um
Second, today's DDPS seminar is open to
external audience. Therefore, no
classified discussion is allowed, so
please watch out.
Finally, the talk today will be recorded
and uploaded in our YouTube channel.
That's about it. Now, let me briefly
introduce our speaker today. It is an
honor to host Dr. Gabor
Csanyi.
Um am I pronouncing your last name?
That's approximately that. We've done
do. What what is the correct one?
Csanyi. Csanyi, okay. Csanyi.
Um Professor Csanyi, he uh who is a
professor of molecular
molecular modeling in the Department of
engineering engineering at the
University of Cambridge Cambridge.
He specializes in atomistic simulation
and multi-scale modeling integrating
quantum mechanics with larger scale
systems. His research focuses on
applying machine learning techniques to
material modeling, particularly in
developing interatomic potentials
derived from ab initio electro
electronic structure data.
Professor Csanyi also explores
statistical challenges in molecular
dynamics such as enhanced sampling
algorithms for exploring the
configuration space of materials and
molecules. He contributes to the
Lennard-Jones Center fostering
collaborations among atomic
scale modeler.
Um today, uh,
Professor Chan will talk about
foundation models for materials, uh,
chemistry. I'm sure we are going to hear
a wonderful talk.
Now, let me ask you informal questions,
um, just to get to know him better and
make this seminar somewhat informal. So,
I
I just, you know,
figured out you have a, um, many, many
different hobbies, um,
uh,
the climbing, hiking, and sailing, and,
um, what, the coffee making?
What is the most, uh,
most enjoyable among What is the number
one,
um, thing you you enjoy among all those?
these these depend on, you know, they're
on different time scales, right? So,
Yeah. I coffee three times a day, and
that's very important. And I get to sail
three times a year, which is becoming
very recently started, and that's
becoming very important.
Oh, okay. Best thing to do is to take
all my coffee equipment and make it on
the boat. So, Let me ask you one more
question
because you mentioned sail, and how
What's the farthest, uh,
the sailing course you took?
From here to outside? No, I mean, I've
spent about five weeks conti- on the
water, you know, sleeping on the boat,
but always docking at night. So, no no
open This is not ocean sailing. This is
more,
um,
coastal.
Wow, that's that sounds fantastic.
do it on the Adriatic, so Adriatic? Or
Mediterranean Sea.
Beautiful. Sounds wonderful.
Jealous. Okay, the stage is yours.
Please.
Thank you very much.
Um,
okay, so, before I start, I want to
emphasize that I'd like to I like people
to uh type questions into the chat as
the talk goes on.
It's uh It's Normally when I speak in
person, I ask people to jump up and down
and interrupt me.
Uh but it's it's harder to do that for
you uh on the on the Zoom. People don't
tend to do that. So, but I think if if
you type in questions as they occur to
you, then that's great. And I can either
address them during the talk or we can
start with that at the end.
Okay, so I'm also conscious that this is
a
more diverse audience than my typical
weekly fortnightly seminar audience. So,
you're not all molecular modelers. So,
I've had a I prepared a a little bit of
a few slides of more extended
introduction to this field.
So, and what you see here is my group at
the I guess a couple of years ago is is
our Christmas party.
Uh and I also have
a very collaborative We have a lot of
lot of international collaborations.
I've just many more in this. I've just
listed the people who've been working
with me for many years.
Okay, so um I want to start by talking
about materials modeling
and how
uh simulating
materials and molecules on the computer,
of course, is done
to uh
to support and experiments and theory uh
and is really a third way of
interrogating uh nature. And there are
um
many many length scales on which uh
modeling is done. So, you have to pick a
length pick Often your
your questions concern a certain length
scale and you have to pick
the appropriate modeling uh
framework, modeling regime, and
technique. So, um on these axes, I have
on the
horizontal axis is capability. So, atoms
So, you talk about the number of atoms
or the time if you're thinking about uh
uh forward integrating Newton's law.
Uh, so the the time trajectory of of uh,
particles. And on the all the way on the
left you have for I just named it
quantum chemistry. So, essentially is
the exact solution or not exact, the
numerically approximated solution of the
exact real Schrödinger equation, the
many-body Schrödinger equation. Um, and
that uh, one can do for very few
particles and for very very few time
steps. But essentially for all intensive
purposes in most of chemistry and most
of material science, we can take that to
be an exact method.
But then, if you want to address higher
length scales, more atoms, longer time
scales, you have to approximate. And you
approximate uh, for a while you
approximate systematically. So, there's
density functional theory here, which is
kind of a workhorse of certainly
materials modeling um, to some extent
uh, chemistry as well. Uh, and and one
can do, you know, 100 atoms and several
hundred atoms and picoseconds, many
picoseconds if you have bigger
computers. Um, but uh, if you're going
uh,
going for longer, then you have to have
these much more drastic approximations
all the way up to, you know, doing
experiments. Um, which is not a modeling
method.
I'll have it I have it on the slide for
a reason you'll see in a second. Um, on
the vertical axis I have
the accuracy or the errors rather. And
these are I call them in eVs
or in factors of KT. But what you see is
that as we approximate these these
errors um, typical errors grow rapidly.
So, how are these methods uh,
parameterized? Uh, so typically let's
talk about force fields, which is
which is what the rest of the seminar is
about. So, you have atoms. You don't
want to have electrons anymore. You just
want to know where the atoms are. How do
they move? And force fields have
typically been parameterized kind of
both from uh, from below. So, let's make
force fields that reproduce some aspects
of quantum mechanics, either density
functional theory or or whatever else or
even better approximation. Or
of course we can parameterize them kind
of upwards. So basically we take force
fields, we give them parameters that
result in
when you simulate with them properties
that you can then compare. And this is
why the chemistry laboratory is here. Uh
you can compare them to experiment.
Um and many, many things
uh many, many force fields have been
built this way and that's how the world
has been operating for the best part of
since computers have been
invented.
And uh what we're trying to do is
something different is to somehow go in
between these expensive quantum
mechanical simulations and the very
crude
and early parameterized force fields
using machine learning. So we're trying
to create a set of
a methods we can call them ML force
fields. Uh they're going to be slower
than the empirical force fields and they
are
purely parameterized from below.
So that's the the key aspect is that we
derive these force fields kind of
rigorously from
quantum mechanics via fitting to data uh
and converging these these approximants.
And the idea is because of this the idea
is that we have no loss of accuracy with
respect to whatever quantum mechanics we
parameterizing. So really we're fitting
the the atomic energies, potential
energy surfaces
uh of atoms as accurately as we desire.
But without then having to solve the
electrons, we hoping to gain and we have
gained uh factors of millions or
billions
in evaluation time. And and what we give
up is not dealing with explicit
electrons, but just following where the
atoms are moving. So I want to show you
a few examples of this and and where we
are uh in this um in this
endeavor.
So, but before that, let me show you
what uh
what molecular dynamics does when you do
it with quantum mechanics. So, this is
sort of what we're trying to replace in
a way. And it's really called first
principles molecular dynamics or ab
initio molecular dynamics, and this is
really a computational microscope for
atomic scale processes. So, just to give
three
diverse examples, you can compute phase
diagrams. The phase diagrams of
materials is one of the most fundamental
question that you can ask about a
material. What's the Is it solid? Is it
liquid? Is it a gas? Um is it And if
it's a solid, what kind of solid? What's
the crystal structure? And density
functional theory has been um really uh
working extremely well for a very wide
range of systems uh predict
verified
to experiment where that's possible, and
people are trusting it to go to extreme
conditions like it was done in here
uh by a paper by Julia Galli and her
team, uh many thousands of kelvins,
terapascals, which are not accessible um
in uh in the laboratory. Another example
is
is aqueous solutions of polyatomic ions.
So, uh of course lots and lots of uh
experiments can access the bulk
solution, and you can compute uh and
measure ionization potentials of these
ions, uh and
you you can't see the labels here, but
basically it's experiment uh versus
theory, uh and DFT gives the right
answer, so you trust uh that you're
describing the physics correctly, and
then you can go in and study details of
solvated ions at the atomic level, which
you are not able to do experimentally.
And the third large area is surface
science. So, uh this is a piece of uh
titania,
uh I think a piece of uh uh one of these
titania surfaces 100 TiO2, and there's
an absorbed molecule on it. And this is
the left picture is experiment, um
but uh so it's under UHV, but you can't
really resolve atoms. You see the
molecules,
uh they move around, they undergo
reactions, they undergo uh
chemisorption, but you don't see the
detail. It the the microscope is just
not
just not resolving enough.
So, on the right-hand side, you see what
people do with molecular modeling, the
density functional theory, you get the
right geometry, you get the correct
energy landscape, and that's People have
been doing this for decades.
So, just zooming out a little bit, uh
basically materials properties, the
ability of thermal and dynamical
uh are is is
com- simulated uh with these kind of
methods. Catalytic reactions,
efficiency, and selectivity has been uh
has enjoyed boom from uh
from materials modeling. Um even
complicated things like drug properties,
solubility, metabolism,
uh of course you're you're only zooming
in to some particular small-scale atomic
process that you
think is the most relevant or is
controlling, for example, at the to the
rate of metabolism for a drug. Um and of
course there's a huge semiconductor
industry,
uh which uh is able to understand its
microscopic uh materials. Uh in the
electronics, the detectors, the defects
that control the behavior of these
devices
all through uh
typically density functional
uh calculations.
So, the computational cost of these
things, and I alluded to this in the
first slide,
uh but here's some more details. So,
uh to do a low-level DFT,
um
it's it's 100 atoms, it's about one
compute node, uh
you know, 100 cores 1 hour to get the
single energy of a single structure.
And this scales with cubically typically
in in most implementations. It scales
cubically with the system size. For
insulators, there are linear scaling
implementations with very large
prefactors. Uh
so, that's a a very niche use. Um if you
want better DFT,
uh then for for those who know it hybrid
functionals, then there's a 20 times
prefactor typically and n to the fourth
scaling. Uh and the gold standard, which
is no longer DFT, but it's a higher
level quantum chemistry, coupled cluster
theory, would have an n to the seventh
scaling. So, this You can see that it's
one isn't going to make very much
progress with these algorithms in terms
of the system sizes that are accessible
due to this steep scaling. And uh and
yet, lots and lots of people use these
methods at the these accessible system
sizes. So, what I show here is a few
years out of date now, but it's national
UK national supercomputer, and it's the
usage by code. And you know, just
listing the code the executable names,
and you see that there's this thing
called VASP, which takes about 35% of
all of the UK's academic computer time.
And all the green bars
uh are all other codes that essentially
do the same thing. So, it's molecular
dynamics with density functional theory.
And if you add them up, then uh about
40% of UK's uh academic supercomputing
is doing molecular dynamics with
explicit quantum mechanics using DFT.
So, what happens when you do that? Uh
you take uh atomic positions from
somewhere,
uh your initial condition, you solve the
Schrödinger equation in this density
functional approximation,
and you get forces on the nuclei,
and then you update the positions using
uh sort of an OD solver OD using
Newton's law. And one when you when you
go through and just look at the
information flow, it is striking that
really almost all the
all the numbers that you compute when
you do the solution is about electrons
and structure and electron density and
orbitals of the electrons. And all of
that is kind of thrown away um
because the only thing that you really
keep out of forces. There's a little bit
depending on the algorithms that you
use, you can in the second step you can
use the previous solution to help
initialize the
the next solution. But the numbers that
I quoted for how expensive this is kind
of already assume that you have warm
starts, that you have good initial
conditions.
So really the idea of deriving
an approximation to the potential energy
surface to the forces is to skip this
step all together and just go from
positions to forces using a perhaps very
complex but still analytically
computable
function that you you you never conjure
up the electronic degrees of freedom. Uh
and that is what's going to give us the
big saving. So really what we need is a
energy function, a potential energy
function of the potential of the atomic
positions that map from R to the 3N to
R. And then the force is just the
gradient of that potential.
So of course this idea is not new and
quantum chemists have been doing this
for for many decades.
But for very small molecules. And the
typical formalisms, the typical
mathematical formalism to
to write down this function don't scale
didn't scale very well. Um they scale
exponentially. Uh the the way the
quantum chemists have been traditionally
doing it for decades ago. So the real
question is can we do it not for small
molecules but for materials in general
and for large molecules and molecular
assemblies,
uh, and and escape the the super
exponential scaling. And, you know,
here's a very small molecule, uh, that
the the
people have the kinds of things that
people have been doing before, and
instead we want to do things like this.
We want to take a battery
and just run the whole thing,
uh, and as if we were as if we were
doing, uh, full quantum mechanics. This
is about, I think, here 3,000 atoms.
So, just to know we're going to do this
is machine learning. And, of course, AI
and machine learning are kind of
everywhere in the news, uh, these days,
and there's hardly a person who hasn't
come across that in some form. So, I
just wanted to share a thought about
this, why am why am I so, uh, excited
about, um, about using machine learning
in this area. Um,
and and you might say that, you know,
there's a lot of talk about AI for
science here, and this is an example of
one of those. Um, I think uh, the the
the computer science companies, the
machine learning AI companies are very
excited because it's one of the safe
applications of AI. You know, it's not
going to kill anyone, um, to do a bit
of, uh, science, uh, directly. So, uh,
so I think that's, uh, that's as opposed
to some other uses of AI. So, uh, I
think that's very safe, um, and um,
but but but the what distinguishes it
from traditional uses of AI is, um,
that, uh,
I think traditional ML and AI solves
problems that already have solutions,
but they want to solve them much much
much cheaper. And that's a, you know, as
a way of
impacting on society, that's huge, but,
you know, we already know how to drive
cars. People drive cars really well.
Making a self-driving car would be an
amazing feat, um, in the sense that it
would change the economy, it would
change the incentives, it would change
society in a city.
But, in terms of what is possible in the
world
cars will be driven around. It's not new
in that sense.
Um but when we apply ML and AI for
science,
we are solving problems
that are previously not solvable at all.
So, intractable completely because they
are very, very expensive due to the
steep scaling of the examples of these
electronic structure methods that I
outlined. So, if I want to take a drug
molecule and ask, "Is it going to bind
to a protein?" And I want the answer
computed because it would be very, very
expensive to test every single idea for
a drug molecule experimentally,
can I do that computationally? We
believe the Schrödinger equation is
certainly describes the system, but with
the electronic structure methods, it is
a absolutely out of the question that
you'll be able to run
the exact Schrödinger equation
on a protein or even density functional
theory on a protein for sufficient
length of time that you could answer
this question. Or
I can run DFT on a on a material
inorganic material for
100 atoms, but I want to study a process
that takes 100,000 atoms or a million
atoms, and so I can't do that with
density functional theory. ML allows us
to create approximants that
with which one can do a simulation that
we couldn't do before. And that's the
big excitement.
So, how is this done? Um
I have I see the first uh interesting
question in the chat, so I'm going to
stop. The question is, "Do these
functions have deterministic solutions
or are they uh or are they
approximations?" So, let me go back to
this. So, I think you you posted this
when I was talking about this map from
V of R V of R the the the energy map
from the atomic positions to the forces.
And I think the answer is that um
within a certain um framework of
electronic structure theory, this map is
exact.
And it's
it one can compute it to arbitrary
precision. Now, when I approximate it,
I'm going to make errors.
And that's not obvious what errors are
acceptable. And that depends on what
you're going to use them for.
Okay, so we're not solving the sort of
probabilistic quantum mechanics here. Uh
we're not saying uh I'm going to have a
stochastic system because quantum
mechanics and measurement is
probabilistic. We're going to
essentially evolve the system
undisturbed. So, the the stochastic
nature of quantum mechanics doesn't
really enter uh into uh into this this
world that I'm describing. I hope that
answered the question.
So, uh
how is this done? Um there are a couple
of components. So, we need
uh
an app we we we want to derive the
energy and the force of an atom. So,
we're going to
that's going to depend on its
neighborhood. So, we're going to need
some kind of descriptor for the atomic
neighborhoods. And that
can and and and similarity become the
defined similarity metrics between
different atomic environments.
And then we need a regression method.
So, that could be uh
what I have here my example is a
Gaussian process regression. Um
or uh one can use a linear regression if
the descriptors are good enough, or one
can use neural network regression. And
we've in the last few years ourselves in
my own group have
uh graduated to using neural networks uh
as regression uh algorithms. But then um
we then need an application uh to do the
regression on, and that's in the case of
the force field, that's typically atomic
energies Uh and their derivatives the
forces but actually the
the idea is more general so you could
take any atomic property and you could
regress
the delta ISO which is the NMR chemical
shift
or the alpha x which is the
polarizability of an atom is a tensor
and you could
regret you could make a model of the
polarizability as a function of the
atomic environment. So
what's then having defined these these
components what you do is you create
yourself a database
of small smallish doable system sizes
where the electronic structure can be
computed that gives you points on the
potential energy surface which you then
interpolate using the regression that
you've chosen and then you test it and
if it's good enough
you do the science if not you go back
and you augment your database you refine
the model.
When we started this 20 years ago the
big question was
how many times you need to go around
this loop and how do you know you need
to test every single time
how does this work in practice? It turns
out that after 20 years that this loop
is really quite
you don't need to do around many times
this is it's quite forgiving.
Maybe 10 times maybe 20 times nowadays
maybe once or already
depending on the application. So this is
this is this converges reasonably
quickly. Just to give you a feeling of
of what is going on in this high
dimensional
in this in this data-driven feelings
here's a I can't draw high dimension so
I've drawn low dimension. Imagine that I
want to fit
um
this dashed curve and I have data points
which are the red and I've chosen here
Gaussian process regression.
There's a lot of choice in these
data-driven regression methods and the
answer is going to depend on it. So here
in this
first row, the only data that I'm
allowing
to go into the regression are the point
values. So, where the What is the value
of the function? And the difference
between the different panels here is
where I take
my
Gaussian basis center locations. So,
when you do Gaussian process regression,
you can choose
where to center your Gaussians and then
you go into make the function as a
linear combination of Gaussians. And you
can see that if I take them at the data
points, I get one kind of answer.
If I
take them the first two here are
identical. If I take them on a regular
grid, I get a different kind of answer.
If I can choose fewer Gaussians and
optimize their location, and I'm going
to get a different answer. And the great
the the blue shading is the uncertainty.
Something that we can do with electronic
structure theory is not just take
function values, but derivatives. So,
the forces are derivatives of the
potential energy, and that's also
essentially available at the same time
for the same cost as the energies. And
here in the second row, I'm doing
exactly the same set of fits, but not to
the function values, but to the
derivatives. And you can see that I'm
getting completely different
approximations.
And sometimes, for example, this one,
all the derivatives are really good, but
there's an overall shift, you know, away
from the function because there's no
information on on where
the where the absolute value is. And if
you use both
derivatives and function values, then
you see that actually all the fits are
much better. And And yet, still you can
get different fits depending on where
you choose
the data the data locations. So, there's
a lot of
learning, human learning, about how to
use these techniques. And, you know,
linear regression is somewhat simpler
than Gaussian process regression, but um
neural network regression is much more
complicated, many more degrees of
freedom, many more choices and hyper
parameters.
Regularization
is an absolutely key aspect of all
machine learning, all data-driven
methods. So, you're making assumptions
about the smoothness of our data and
make choices about how strong those
assumptions are and that influences the
the fits
to a great extent. So, I I I here I've
drawn a very brief
graphical history of the history of ML
potentials, so that these ML fits to uh
uh to the potential energy surface. And
of course, the origins go back many
decades and even before 2007, people
were making low-dimensional fits,
particularly to molecules, a few atom
molecules. Uh and you can describe
here's the potential energy and some
cartoon of the potential energy
landscape and you go somewhere to some
local minimum and you take a few data
points and you're approximating that
local minimum using one of these
regression talks. And then a big
breakthrough came in 2007 with Jörg
Behler and Michele Parrinello's paper uh
where they've created new descriptors
and that allowed them to make fits in
high dimensions, so hundreds of
dimensions. And in particular for
materials, but also larger molecules
too. And the way to imagine that is that
there are now many local minima uh and
you take much more data, uh hundreds,
thousands, tens of thousands of data
points and your regression method is
flexible enough. They used neural
networks, feedforward, simple MLPs, um
but with many, many parameters and
well-crafted descriptors of the local
environment and so they could get very
high accuracy in the locations, in the
local environments, local minima where
they had data.
And
then
uh myself included and lots of others uh
have uh evolved and improved upon these
methods in the sub- subsequent 15 years.
But just uh about 2 years ago, um
again, there was a sort of a leap, I
think, uh which is making models that
have very wide transferability, very
large generalization. And the way to
imagine that is that you fit
to just a few data points, relatively
few, just in a very narrow part of
configuration space
uh compared to
everything that you could think of, and
that gives you a potential energy
landscape that's kind of approximately
correct uh everywhere, very far away uh
from uh from the training data. And
that's quite unusual. It was very, very
unexpected, and this is what the last uh
5 minutes of my talk uh will be about.
Uh and
and people were very surprised, and it's
quite unusual, I think, even in the sort
of ML and AI uh world.
And what you can But of course, it's not
accurate exactly everywhere else. So, if
you want to make it more accurate
somewhere else, because that's where
your science is, then you take data
there. You can explore it approximately,
because you have a potential that they
can do anything. Uh and then you take
new data there, you can refine easily
with very little data, and get high
accuracy uh wherever uh you wherever you
actually did put some data. So, we'll
come back to the end. But uh let's go
back just to illustrate kind of
quantitatively uh the breakthrough uh of
2007, and this is actually the paper is
from 2014, so a few years later, but
this is the first time that we've seen
uh
some
being able to solve a task that um
that really meant means something from a
materials modeling point of view. So, we
have uh here tungsten, uh and the errors
of and empirical potentials on tungsten
elastic constants, vacancy formation
energy, surface energies. And you can
see that these three different models,
the Bonder potential, the modified
embedded atom method, and the finish
singular potential, the this sort of
derived each 10 years apart, didn't
really make much improvement in the
overall accuracy with respect to a
decent DFT reference.
That's not why they were derived. They
were derived and created to solve a
certain science problem with trends and
empirical ideas. So, I'm not These were
These were excellent methods for what
they were describing, but they were not
making progress
in towards actually fitting the
potential energy surface. And when we
turned on
a set of descriptors and in our case
Gaussian process regression,
you just nail all of these things.
And to to to arbitrary accuracy. You
want better accuracy, it's not so hard
to get. Overall, the meV per atom
accuracy that we can get for materials
is still true today, and it's actually
now limited not by the fitting method,
but by the underlying DFT data. So, of
course, when you do the density
functional theory, there are still
numerical approximations, and they
conspire to have a
a noise of about a meV per atom.
So, let me I have a slide with
equations, and I know it's for most
people learning new equations from a few
minutes in slides is is in a talk is not
the ideal, but I just have them so that
to give you a glimpse of how the um
fitting methods have evolved and how the
descriptors evolved over the last 15
years. Uh there's lots of at least in my
own group, and there's lots of
analogies.
Uh maybe gives you a sense of the kind
of mathematics that underlies
uh this this business. So, the the
smooth overlap of atomic positions,
which was used to do the tungsten model
that I showed you just now uh was made a
year earlier and it's we start by um
having you know a central atom I with
neighbors J and we create an atomic
environment density. So, this row I is
all the atoms around uh a central atom I
and we put a little Gaussian on each
neighbor and this row is then expanded
in a
basis of uh YLMs and radial basis
functions RN with expansion
coefficients.
Earlier on we used to keep the sigma
finite. You'll see what later on it's
actually perfectly okay to just have
delta functions on each neighbor. That's
the same as the sigma equals zero limit.
And then you can write the coefficients
just as the basis functions evaluated at
the neighbor position.
And um
and that takes So, this these
coefficients then are uh permutation
invariant. It doesn't matter which order
you consider the neighbors in this sum
is a permutation invariant uh operation.
Uh but we also would like the
uh the descriptor to be rotationally
invariant. I don't care how an atomic
neighborhood is oriented. So, it turns
out it turned out that if you take a
square of these C coefficients, C dagger
C, C Normally they're complex if you
choose complex spherical harmonics, and
you sum them over M, then you get this
power spectrum which we call it P
NN'L so they have three indices
uh for each atom I and it turns out that
that's a rotational invariant and it
contains a rich description of the uh of
the atomic neighborhoods. So, it took
about six years and Ralph Drautz uh to
realize that this scheme that we
concocted up here can be vastly
generalized and improved. Uh and that's
he called that the atomic cluster
expansion. And the paper's from 2019 um
and I'm switching notation because I'm
keeping to the notation of the of
Ralph's paper. But basically uh
but but there are close analogies
because it's really a generalization of
SOAP. So, you create these pair bases,
which is just the radial R times Ylm,
and now the R can depend not just on N,
but also L, uh and uh you can the R can
depend on the element index if you have
different elements, uh chemical
chemical elements in your system, and
you sum up the the phi's evaluated the
basis functions evaluated at each
neighbor, uh and uh Ralph called this
the atomic basis A, and that's basically
this plays the role of C uh in in the
SOAP formalism. And then, uh in the next
step, so C and A are analogous, and then
the construction of the rotation
invariant is kind of done in two steps,
uh but the first one is the product of
the A's with itself, and that's if you
just product two A's, so if new here is
two, then that's exactly the same as
what we did in SOAP. But what Ralph
realized is that you can actually do
this to arbitrary number of A's, uh and
you get a many-body potential, and it's
not expensive to do that, um or not
necessarily expensive, and you get a
tensor.
And you get this this bold A, which is
now a many-body uh representation, and
and this is now the critical insight,
you can simply make that rotation
invariant as well. Just as we summed
over M here, now we have to sum over L
and M,
and you get Clebsch-Gordan coefficients,
they're more complicated than just no,
the coefficient one here. But when you
do that, you get these B bases, which we
call the A bases. It's a complete
linearly independent rotational
permutational invariant uh basis for
atomic neighborhoods. And so, we use the
A bases uh for um for a number of
applications. I'll show you one in a
second, and it's much faster in its
latest implementation, in large part due
to Kristof Wardner um who's at UBC now
and
you know the ACE in in I I think in all
aspects kind of supersedes
the the earlier SOAP representation. And
so there is
there's more complexity, there are more
parameters, but there's higher accuracy.
And then
the the latest sort of a couple of years
ago, what we're using now is a
generalization of ACE
and that's called MACE.
It's multi ACE or
message passing ACE. We don't really
define what the M stands for necessarily
uniquely, but what's going on is that we
create a phi. Please ignore the C and
the H in the first round. I'll come back
to that. In the first instance they
don't they are not here.
I've just written the general form. But
then using those phis we sum them up
over neighbors here and then taking a
clue from
graph neural networks and the
deep learning architectures, we have a
linear multiplying this this tensor.
Which
which kind of mixes up the different
components and these are trainable. So
this is now no longer a linear model
like ACE is.
But the tensor product here is exactly
analogous the Clebsch-Gordan product
here.
And and and the summing over LM is
exactly analogous. But in as opposed to
ACE we don't stop here, but we
have atomic features H which are which
are start out as the identity, but now
they update them using some waiting
linear weights using the B functions and
we take the the updated features and we
plug them back in here.
So that's why I had the more complicated
formula for phi because we go through
this whole process twice. Now with the
updated atomic features H, that's why I
need the Clebsch-Gordan in the second
round because I need to sum up
the product of H and R and Y and that
requires an extra
Clebsch-Gordan sum to identify the
spherical the correct components of the
spherical tensor of this this product.
And then we go through the same summing
over the J's, self-producting
and then summing over the Clebsch-Gordan
coefficients. And the second round of
B's we just take as the descriptors. And
the the main person behind all this code
and ideas is Ilya Batatia, graduate
student here in Cambridge. So let me
show you a few examples. So what we were
able to do
with them
with A's is uh
a very large simulation. What's going on
here?
A large simulation of perovskites. So
the this is the cesium lead iodide
structure here which is sort of a
frustrated network frustrated grid of
these octahedra and because they are
frustrated in terms of size
at different temperatures they do
different things. So experimental phase
transitions are here and here. This is
the the vertical axis here are the
pseudo cubic lattice constants and you
can see that at different temperatures
you break the symmetry and get instead
of one at high temperature now two and
then finally three different lattice
constants in the three different
directions. And a simple empirical
potential really just doesn't get those
particularly
at all. Whereas the A's model gets the
transition temperatures of those phase
transitions
really quite accurately. There is an
offset here of the absolute value of the
lattice constant and that's just simply
a well-known DFT error. The approximate
the DFT approximation underestimates
the lattice constants. But once
we we can train this model and once you
we train it typically iteratively, I
have a
little example here
of a of a movie where this is not
exactly the cesium version. This is a
hybrid perovskite, but essentially we
run MD, wait for it to explode, and then
pick those configurations, put them back
in the database, and after 16
iterations, and this is the loop that I
mentioned at the beginning,
you get a stable potential which can run
high temperature MD. And once you can do
that, you can study something that
people want to study about this
material. So back to the cesium version,
what you see here is a
100,000 atoms run for 2 nanoseconds.
Completely impossible with electronic
structure method, but what the colors
show here are the X direction, Y
direction, and Z direction tilts of the
different of the octahedra, how they
relieve their frustration. And what you
see here, and what people didn't know
before this simulation, is that there
are large domains, and in the X, Y, and
Z, they don't correlate. So this is a
simulation at 500 K, so it's one of
these intermediate phases, and people
didn't know whether that average
intermediate phase is how is that a
combination of
the lower symmetry phases or
how does it what's the relationship
between the different tilts that are
possible in this system. And now we
know,
and people use that in thinking about
the rationalizing the observations that
you make experimentally of these
perovskites.
So
this was the wrong direction.
Okay. So let me show you now jump a
little bit forward, and let me show you
a couple of results from May. So this is
an our attempt our first attempt at
making
a transferable organic force field. So
this is not materials, but my molecules,
and we used the Spice dataset that was
published quite some number of years
ago. It's a million molecules calculated
with a very high level of DFT. It's
omega B97M.
It's a hybrid range separated hybrid
meta GGA
for those who know it. It contains 10
different elements, lots of different
molecules, and we take those molecular
energies and forces, create fit a MACE
model, and then predict properties that
people actually want to know. So, here
are some torsional profiles. You take
these molecules that have two rings and
a single bond between them, and those
two rings can rotate quite freely.
And we can get the potential energy
barrier and the full barrier profile for
that rotation. And the sort of gold
standard coupled cluster here is the
black, and what you see here is the the
level of DFT that Spice uses is the
gray, so that matches the black really
quite well. And three different MACEs,
this blue, green, and red is the blue,
green, and red here. And you can see
that the large version of MACE with
couple of million parameters in
scattered around that formula that I put
up sort of gets the gets the torsional
profile, you know, within line with the
accuracy here. And then you take this
model, and you do
much larger simulations. So, you can do,
you know, all of these polypeptides in
vacuum, and they fold up. This is
polyalanine, and you know, the largest
peptide in the database was your
dipeptide. So, there is a lot of
extrapolation to larger system sizes.
And now we can do something that that is
quantitative that people actually care
about, which is something like
solvation. So, part of that is hydration
free energy. So, what's the free energy
difference between taking between an
isolated molecule in vacuum at finite
temperature and in a box of water. So,
now we're talking about the simulation
of 1,000 atoms.
And experiment here is blue.
Orange and red are typical empirical
models
that have been fitted to solvation free
energies. So, for small molecules, they
basically get it right. They've been
parameterized to get it right. But, the
MACE-FF
gets it right for the right reason
because the potential energy and the
forces are quantum mechanically correct.
And so, this is just a few examples from
the first pre-print of this paper, but
since then we've done, you know, dozens
and dozens of larger molecules and this
this trend continues. And now you can
also do more things that the drug
industry cares about. So,
log the log P is essentially the free
energy difference between water
solvation and a fatty this is octanol
solvation. So, a much more aliphatic
solvent. And again, experiment here is
blue.
Typical force field is gray. And MACE
is is green. And so, you get the right
answer for the right reason. This is a
thing that drug companies would want to
measure
about the proposed drug molecule. So,
now let me come to the sort of the last
5 minutes.
And I promised to talk about the very
general MACE force fields. And the
question is can we make a force field
for all of materials, all materials? And
I didn't think so, but other people did.
So, credit to Shu-Ping Ong
at at UC SD who have been trying to fit
large material databases
for many years. And you know, the
accuracy is kind of improved, but people
weren't really using them for anything
else other than what Shu-Ping Ong
designed them for, which is to filter
proposed crystal structures where in the
context of material discovery.
But, but just very recently, so
I I guess
maybe 18 months ago, uh uh we we had to
um
uh
friends of ours uh fitted our model to
the same database that uh Shopee used,
which is the Materials Project. It's got
about 1.6 million structures. It covers
89 elements. And there is a leaderboard
online called Matbench Discovery. And
with a little bit of help uh the the
model did very well. Oh, what I'm
showing here is the just to give you a
visual guidance on what's in the
training database. So, lots and lots of
inorganic materials. Actually, all known
inorganic materials. But that's it. Just
bulk. Just very near equilibrium.
And so, in uh in November 23, uh our
model so was at the head of that
leaderboard. And this leader the all all
these columns are very correlated.
They're basically how well do describe
the energy of a new proposed structure
with respect to the convex hull of those
of those elements. And uh
I think around that time us and other
people's successes kind of led to a to a
little bit of a a race uh to see if how
good can uh can one be. And a few months
later, uh Google uh released their GNoME
model. And it became much better uh than
than what our model achieved. But of
course, on much much larger data set.
So, we fitted to 1.6 million structures.
They fitted to 89 million structures.
That were secret. So, nobody knows what
GNoME was fitted to. Um
and their model was also much larger,
which is all fine. But really, the
training data uh scale-up was very
significant here. Um and and since then,
every month there's a new model here.
So, Matters came from Microsoft or from
Orbital Materials, Equiformer V2 from
Facebook. You can see that this this
scale is getting saturated. You know,
the the maximum effort score possible
when you get every energy right is 1.0.
Uh so this this thing keeps changing all
the time. Now, if you introduce a metric
that's not just about energies but
forces, so that's the kappa
uh SRME, so that's the uh root mean
square error on uh thermal conductivity
of selected materials, then that
requires you to have really good forces,
and you see that now you don't
correlate. So now things that are not so
good on not as good as the best one on
energies, a late a maze model fitted on
12 million
uh structures um
actually uh does uh did the best. This
is already very old, so if you check the
web page now, you will see even later
models doing very well.
But this is still in domain testing.
What about out of domain? What happens
if you take one of these models and you
just start doing an MD simulation of
your favorite uh
materials problem. So here we tried
that. Um sort of a anecdotal story of of
why nobody expected this to work. Uh
here's the graphic piece of the graphite
fitted on organic uh electrolyte and and
lithium salt in there. This is the the
the a model composition of a battery uh
and in previous simulations, previous
attempts of simulating a system like
this, such a simulation would just
explode
due to the huge variety of structures
that you can get. Uh when you fit it
simulated in one of these models that's
fitted to the Materials Project, you get
a stable simulation.
You can run this at 500 K for a
nanosecond,
and it just works. Uh and eventually the
lithiums find their way into the
graphite, and
you get intercalation. So this was
completely unexpected and a huge
surprise.
And then uh we got to
uh go crazy, and every student start
tried this model on their different um
systems, so not just batteries, but the
hybrid perovskites, polymerization of
sulfur, amorphous carbon quenching,
aqueous interfaces of salty solutions uh
to various solids, hydrogen combustion
catalysis, dichalcogenide 2D materials,
defects in semiconductors. All of these
just worked. We couldn't find a system a
real materials modeling problem where
you started the simulation in reasonably
initial conditions and it just basically
did the the chemically roughly the right
thing.
So, it didn't explode.
Basic chemistry was happening.
So, the result of that is this
paper with nearly 90 authors, not all of
whom I know
in person, so that was a very
interesting experience. It was all
written in a matter of 6 weeks.
And it's basically the
a few highlights and then 50 different
examples of all the ones that I showed.
Basically saying, "What can you get from
such a generic model?"
Some of some of the highlights that
we're particularly intrigued by
this example is moths. So, we take the
foundation model and test it on 20,000
moths, none of which are in the training
database, and almost all of it the
energy correlation curve is nearly
perfect. The ones that are in this cloud
here are it's sort of a numerical
discrepancy. The pseudo potential used
in DFT So, the dipole of the DFT
parameter functions is not the same for
those. That was was trend and that gives
you an energy offset.
But, the the functionality is perfectly
reasonable. So, if you take one of these
moths, moth 74, and you here's a little
carbon dioxide molecule, and you compute
the free energy
of carbon dioxide as a function of
space, then you basically get the same
answer as you would have got as people
got before we fitted machine learning
potential to this moth with lots and
lots of DFT calculations specific to
this system. And this is not an easy
thing. If you take an empirical
potential, you get the wrong answer. So,
now that you have an off-the-shelf
model, you can do screening of moles.
You can take seven different ions, 14
different ligands, just the example
here, and you can do nanoseconds
simulations in a matter of days. Here's
hydrogen combustion. You start out with
hydrogen gas and oxygen gas. You let it
go, and you get the right things
happening. You get water formation,
and these are the different rates of
water formation as a function of density
and temperature. And when you look at it
in detail, you get all the right
intermediates forming, and none of this
is in the database
by itself. You have salts in the
database, essentially, as inorganic
salts is the closest we get. In the In
the manuscript, we kind of identify for
each application what is the closest
that you get to to those atomic
environments in the database. So,
we're going to have computational
scaling. So, um this is most of this
work is is work of Chuck Witt, who's now
at Harvard. And what you should get out
of these plots is that is the number of
atoms, and this is the throughput in
million steps per day, so nanoseconds
per day if you're using femtosecond time
steps. And these solid curves are, you
know, using a single, in this case, a
CPU, so one node.
And for a very small system, you can get
to 10 nanoseconds. And of course, as you
the system size goes up, you get
the proportionally lower throughput. But
for a thousand atoms, you can easily do
two or three nanoseconds. And if you are
willing to put to throw more resources
at it, so weak scaling, throw more
atoms, throw more CPUs, you can you get
these essentially flat curves. So, we
can sustain
five nanoseconds per day essentially
forever
as you grow your system. And we've done
up to millions of atoms. And a similar
things happen on a GPU.
So GPUs of course per flop are much
cheaper. You sustain about between one
and two
nanoseconds per day again
reasonably flat.
And and Chuck is working there is a few
factors within
in this steel model that we could
squeeze out we think. Um
Let me show you some caveats because
there are always some.
So
the materials project as I said contains
really only near equilibrium structures.
So if you highly compress the system
then you get in our original fits you
basically got nonsense. So this is a
number of arsenic structures where if
you really really compress them you get
this as the potential energy curve which
is kind of rubbish right? When you
compress the material the energy should
just go up. And it's not so surprising
this is the data set with this gray
histogram and none of these distances
were ever near the data set. So in
density there is very little
extrapolation of this earlier
method. And really tweaking the model
size doesn't really help.
What does help is splining into a ZBL
reference. So we know that when atoms
are super close less than one angstrom
then actually the ZBL potential is a
decent approximation
and we also put in the isolated atom
reference as these are the two extremes
and with a few more tweaks distance
transforms on the
transform function on the interatomic
distances and normalizing the densities
in the intermediate layers of our graph
neural network you can actually get from
exactly the same data now we get really
very reasonable compression curves. It
absolutely no data here we get smooth
connection to the splines.
So
let me see I'm basically out of time
although we started about eight minutes
late. Let me just show you one slide on
fine tuning because I mentioned at the
beginning. So, what else do we do apart
from getting things approximately
correct? So, this is the normal maze
embedding
of the of the atoms into the
neighborhood and then two ace layers and
the readout. Well, we can split the
readout into two and on one of them we
aim to get the original data and if you
have 100 configurations of your favorite
new system, we can create a new readout
head that that gets that correct, but
with very little new data. This is
called multi-head fitting and it works
remarkably well. So, here's another
example from the
manuscript that I showed with the 90
authors. So, you take you think about
lithium nickel oxide, which is from a
prototype battery cathode
and it undergoes young teller distortion
at high temperature. So, the ab initio
molecular dynamics shows you this is the
nickel oxygen
distance
histogram and at low temperatures, you
see these two peaks very clearly and
they merge at high temperature and a
specific temperature. And
if
this is the the the original
off-the-shelf mace MP
has the physics of young teller in
there,
but it's not really right. You don't get
it at the right temperature, you don't
get the right distribution. 100
configurations randomly picked from an
MD from this kind of MD and fine tuning
and you get essentially
indistinguishable performance from the
AMD.
So, I have I see a very very relevant
question in the chat. What would happen
if you just did normal fine tuning, so
not multi-head? And what happens then is
that you get you go you undergo
catastrophic forgetting.
So, basically for a few epochs things
get better, but and essentially you end
up completely over-fitting your 100 new
configurations and the model is
completely unusable and unstable.
Of course, if you create if you include
tens of thousands of new configurations,
then you're essentially making a not a
universal model, but you're now making a
model for that particular material. Uh
but the point of the multi-head is that
you can get away with very little data
as long as you uh you do the fine-tuning
in this way.
So, uh okay, here's another example
which I now don't go through. It's in
the It's in the archive on catalysis. Um
let me just say that data matters. So,
if you do instead of 1.6 million, you go
up to 12 million data points, that's the
Alexandria data set, then many things
improve dramatically. So, here's um
the uh sort of the normalized
displacement along 111 direction of the
BCC metals, and this is the stacking
fault energy. And you see the DFT is in
black and the original MACE model is in
red, and these are very delicate. These
are just, you know, eVs per angstrom
squared. And without any fine-tuning, if
you take the MACE MPA, and all these
models, by the way, are available uh for
download on our website, you get
essentially perfect curves without any
fine-tuning. Same thing happens for
amorphous carbon.
So, really this is the closing slide
now. Uh and what I promised is that
foundation models are systematic uh
derivations, and what we we we're we're
almost gotten there generally. So, we
Our foundation model kind of takes us
here in in error, so we can do very
large systems
at at the sort of approximate level, but
with fine-tuning, with a tiny bit of
fine-tuning, we can get down to the ab
initio accuracy and have models that are
million times faster. Um let me skip
some of this and just uh put this slide
up with some conclusions,
uh and uh happy to answer questions.
Thank you. Thank you so much for the
wonderful talk.
Um
Yeah, Sh- Shivanand um
he
asked the questions, you know, related
to the last question.
Yeah, so to find you. So,
so question I mean
I'm not quite sure what you're asking.
If you do continue learning without the
multi-head,
the catastrophic forgetting happens.
Training more doesn't help. It It makes
it worse. So, I think that uh this idea
of This is called in the in the AI
business, this is called multi-head
fine-tuning with replay. So, you're
getting some of the old data. The nice
thing about it is that you don't need
all of the data. So, if you're not
training one of these models from
scratch on the original MP Materials
Project data, it's about 2,000 GPU
hours.
If you go to the latest data set uh from
Facebook, which is 100 million
materials, uh so, that's 100 times
bigger. We need 10 times more data.
Interestingly, it's about the the square
root. So, um
so, 20,000 hours, and that's not
insignificant. But, that's why the
multi-head only uses a few percent of
the original data, randomly picked, uh
and that's enough in typical
applications to uh to avoid the
catastrophic forgetting.
So, uh
yes, Amjad, uh
you're asking a question about the
scaling of the model uh at
at high densities. And I think that is
absolutely true. So, currently, we use a
scheme where the cutoff is fixed in
angstrom,
and there I've seen some very
interesting ideas about changing that.
So, some people might want to use a
certain number of nearest neighbors.
Uh the one has to be very careful with
that because
you have to make sure that the model is
still continuous, so that when one
nearest neighbor gets replaced by
another nearest neighbor that's on the
opposite side of the atom,
you have to make sure that uh that the
the model remains continuous. Uh but, I
think there are tricks for that. Um I
think it might be interesting to uh to
rather than doing it by the number of
neighbors to have some kind of cut off
that's
uh that's adaptive to density. Uh I
haven't quite thought that through
precisely how that would work. But I
think it's certainly true that when you
squeeze a material very much, there is a
kind of scaling that um that the Hessian
is um
decays. The interaction decays by the
number of atom hops rather than by some
uh absolute scale.
So, uh let me just go through some
number of questions. So, uh Yeah. The
question is uh
so, the matter published models
uh
using uh MP and OMAT. Uh and
the question is what about uh
multiple data sets? So, that's very
interesting. Uh
we are many people are playing with
that. Uh the question really is
consistency. So, um OMAT uses a set of
um
DFTs that's really quite close to MP,
not quite the same. Um
and and so, you can use them together.
But actually, you might be better off
doing a kind of multi-head where
not the fine-tuning multi-head, but
where you put the different DFTs on
different heads.
Um
and certainly, I think one can't just
unite data sets that are done with
completely incompatible DFTs.
I don't think anyone is really doing
that. Um
next question, uh are there systematic
tests on the anharmonic
and non-equilibrium properties? Uh
absolutely so. So, the kappa uh SRME is
is an is an anharmonic thermal
conductivity. And there are lots of
properties that people are interested in
that are much more anharmonic than that.
So, diffusivities,
uh you know, in the smooth solid and the
liquid. And you know, the the literature
the recent literature is is full of uh
of tests like that. And particularly,
actually, the the people who make uh MP
fits uh
very often Shubin Ong, uh the Gnome uh
Google community, uh lots of other
people are interested in not so
out-of-domain uh
universal potentials like I am, but they
want to do materials discovery on
inorganic crystals, but they're
interested in complex properties. So,
things like lithium diffusivity in a
solid-state uh ionic conductor. And you
know, there are excellent uh results uh
on that. Um
Okay, next question. Uh foundation
models perform well on general tasks
close to the training set.
Well, I don't think so. I mean, I've
been trying to show you that uh
that they perform well very far from the
training set. Um so, I'm not quite sure
what you mean. Are you mean Do you mean
foundation models in general in the AI
business? Yeah, that's I think
foundation models of the kind that I'm
talking about
are precisely the opposite. Uh they
perform
amazingly well, surprisingly well,
shockingly well very far away from the
training set. Yeah. And we don't know
why.
So, I have to be very honest that we
don't really know what aspect of quantum
mechanics is being captured here in this
architecture, in this GNN uh message
passing uh architectures that allows
this kind of transferability. Why are
you getting hydrogen burning chemistry
correctly essentially when you've seen
ice and uh
some some inorganic crystals. It's
unclear. That's a a very very active uh
research point. Um
What are my thoughts about leveraging
foundation models for targeted tasks?
So, I'm not quite sure what you mean. I
think because in these uh in in I think
what I've showed you here is that there
is this extreme generalization. So,
maybe you can specify better
uh what you mean. I think you also
mentioned distillation. I think there is
a a role for distillation. These models
are
much slower than empirical potentials,
much slower than any AM.
And one could take these foundation
models, generate lots of data, fine-tune
them, and then transfer that onto a much
simpler model.
Fit fit a very fast, very small model
onto very large amounts of data. And
there's lots of nice papers coming out
of that. But Joshua, if you want to if I
misunderstood your question,
I apologize. You may want to clarify.
Um
Training specialized versus
how close you are on the training set.
I'm not sure what you meant. Yeah, I
think Yo Joshua, do you want to unmute
and
clarify?
If Joshua is still there.
Uh yeah.
No.
He says ions in the
in the chat. Um
Okay, so yeah, I I I do see that the
extreme generalizations
of your model. But the the just to
understand the mechanism, you you train
on the many different um you know,
molecular structures
and relatively smaller size, right?
Yeah, the almost all of it is less than
50 atom. Yeah, and then you you use
learn the the force fields.
And when you combine them to apply that
to the much larger scale, much larger
number of molecules and atoms uh
problems, you just use the regressions
like a GNN and GP and
you don't impose the the physics when
you when you assemble them in your No,
no, no. I mean each Look, underneath
this there's a locality decomposition.
So, quantum mechanics gives you one
energy for the entire system and the set
of forces, which is the derivative of
that one energy, total energy. And these
ML models decompose the total energy
into atomic contributions.
So, that's that decomposition is
essential, right? That's We write the
total energy, we approximate the total
energy as a sum of local energies.
That's what's learned and that's why
these models are extensive. You know,
all interatomic potentials do that. Even
empirical potentials do that. I didn't
emphasize this, but all potentials
make that approximation that you divide
up the total energy. And that's that's
the learning task.
I see. I see. is to is to learn the
local contribution to the total energy
that you compute quantum mechanically. I
see. Maybe uh as Joshua mentioned, ions.
So, it's it's sort of one of the um
large models will be computationally
How to use the foundation model in
large-scale simulation where the large
models will be computationally limiting.
Um
So,
I Yeah, I I think, you know, if we we
can do 1,000 atoms for 10 nanoseconds
per day, but if you want to do a million
atoms,
uh and
well, if you have the biggest the kind
of supercomputer access that you guys
have, then that would probably work uh
for a nanosecond. But, you know, I
accept, of course, that these are 100
times slower than empirical potentials.
So, I think I agree that there's a lot
of scope in distillation. There's a lot
of scope in
uh making a specialized model out of the
foundation model
with generating lots and lots of
training labels using the foundation
model or a fine-tuned large model on a
small on a specific system, and then you
train a small model. Yeah. Uh uh, which
is much faster. And and I think that is
definitely a a viable approach, and I
think many people are playing with it.
Absolutely.
Awesome. Uh, yeah, there's question
about Omol. So, we've already fit Omol,
uh, and uh, we we're working with uh,
with the Facebook team. Uh, we have uh,
we have essentially matched their
published model on Omol,
uh, with a few more tweaks, uh, and
we're studying what kind of tweaks are
necessary. I think the Omol, uh, data
set is super exciting. Uh, I was part of
the with the advisory group, uh, who
helped uh, create that data set, and I
think it's a
well,
it's it's an order it's two orders of
magnitude larger, approximately, than
uh, than the previous largest um, than
the previous consistent data set, which
had that level of electronic structure.
And so, and it's much more diverse, and
much better converge. So, I think, uh,
there's huge excitement in the molecular
ML community about it, and we're going
to, um, use, uh, and uh, use Omol for
the next Omol 25 for the next couple of
years, particularly as we go to charge
self-consistent models. So, one of the
things that I didn't talk about at all
is how to bring in electrostatics. Lots
of people have done work on that, uh,
and uh, we, uh, also want to make MACE,
uh, electrostatically aware, and the
Omol data set, uh, will be, uh, an
essential part of this. Uh, I just wish
that OMA was as carefully constructed as
Omol, and, uh, and I think there is
going to be another push,
uh, in the community to bring up the
materials,
uh, model to that to the Omol kind of
standard of rigor. Um, it's hard to go
beyond GGA, right? So, we will not for a
while we're not going to see imminently
100 million mark materials computed with
a hybrid functional. Uh
because, you know, it's 100 times more
expensive than GGA. But, you know, in a
few years, maybe that's possible. Uh and
then one can then really think about
uniting materials and molecules. So,
that's a a very big outstanding
challenge is that the best functional
for molecules doesn't really
or it's too expensive or doesn't really
work for materials or metals. And the
other way around, the things that work
really well for materials or acceptably
well for materials don't are not really
acceptable for a high-quality molecular
work. And but I think with extra
compute, um perhaps uh we could get a a
molecular material consistent data set,
which of course then opens up hybrid
systems, interfacial systems.
And that's uh that's something that's uh
really exciting.
Okay. I have another question. So, you
um
um I think I heard you were saying that
um this foundation model is only
applicable for the near equilibrium
state.
No, it was trained on near equilibrium.
Oh, trained on the near equilibrium. But
it's applicable look, it's I've shown
you many
it's applicable everywhere, right?
That's the exciting thing.
That it does
far far out of equilibrium stuff roughly
correctly so that you can uh
find you can explore
reaction networks. For example, on
catalysis, the example I didn't have
time to show is that you can explore
reaction networks because the
approximate landscape of troughs and
peaks of the molecule potential energy
on the surface is approximately right.
And then by fine-tuning, you can get the
barriers correctly. Is there a reason
why you um
it is limited to um
you know, those training data, like the
near equilibrium training data? No, no,
no. I'm just I
I'm just saying that that's I'm just
telling you a story. That's what
happened. That training data was
available. It was near equilibrium. And
that's the shocking thing is that that
was enough.
Um the O O map training data, 100
million, is much less close to
equilibrium. It includes a lot of MD
data.
So, I think people are making these data
sets. There's no reason to have that
limitation. I think that the real
surprise was that that it was the
diversity that was
critical.
The diversity of all materials coupled
with the maze architecture and the this
message passing
um
architecture
uh
was sufficient to extrapolate from this
very in some ways very limited training
data
to to any kind of material. Amazing.
Okay. The Logan So, Logan is asking
about uh mixed GGA hybrid. Uh people are
playing with that. Certainly, one option
is to fine-tune. So, I talked about
fine-tuning in the context of
going to a certain part of the landscape
or for certain material, but you can
easily fine-tune
for changing function. And you can
change uh you can go to a hybrid for a
specific system, and that's not a
problem at all. Um
whether how to do that for a foundation
model, right? Can you have a foundation
model with a GGA head and a hybrid head?
How much hybrid data you need to do
that? Very good question. I I'm sure
people are trying that out. Uh that's
that's an obvious
experiment.
Okay. Is there any other questions?
If not, let's thank our speaker uh
Professor Shani uh for the wonderful
talk and also the discussion like Q&A
sessions.
Um that's awesome, like I mean
as you said, it's a mysterious, but it's
it works fantastic. That's awesome.
Okay, thank you very much for listening.
Okay.
Um
So, that ends the seminar today. Let me
stop the recording.